we have a grooming update from the new
york times
just when you think the grooming has
reached the maximum amplitude they turn
the grooming up to 11. headline in the
new york times the books about sex that
every family should read that's going to
be the title of my next blank book
the books about sex that every family
should read a comprehensive guide and
it's going to be 250 blank pages
maybe i won't be able to use that exact
title because the new york times wrote a
serious earnest article listing these
books the books
are listed here and described by elaine
blair
elaine blair let's just let's just cut
right back to the biography
is a
los angeles-based critic and an
inaugural winner of some prize for
literary criticism
a left-wing writer
describes him or herself as trans mask
all sorts of things it's kind of like on
twitter when you see somebody's pronouns
in the bio you know that that person is
deluded and is going to say really crazy
things so what are the books that we
have to read about sex to our kids
just i'll just open right from the top
of the article about eight years ago
when my daughter was in preschool i went
to the children's alcove of our local
library and found the book that i'd
heard was the standard bearer of liberal
sex education for younger school-aged
children it's so amazing a book about
eggs sperm
birth babies and families
this is when this person's daughter was
in preschool
so i gotta go get the book on
on sperm and eggs and sex for my
preschooler
it's so amazing covered many subjects
anatomy gender fertilization gestation
birth love heterosexual intercourse
sexual orientation child sex abuse and
hiv you've got to tell your preschooler
about hiv what if your preschooler wants
to go to a gay bath house certainly your
preschooler needs to know the risks of
hiv right you've got to what three year
old doesn't need to know about this
in a chapter called what sex an
unclothed man and woman partly covered
by a blue blanket kissed in missionary
position when two people care for each
other sexual intercourse is very loving
i read in the accompanying text
but but so at this point we should
obviously take the book burn it
chase the author out of town on a rail
ban this from the libraries for
three-year-olds should obviously not be
reading this but
this author in the new york times her
problem with the with the book
is that the book was not radical enough
because
it says then came the next chapter
what's love with pictures of smiling
families and couples in many different
configurations watching tv eating meals
cuddling walking dogs with nearby text
explaining the meaning of words like
straight gay and lesbian now something
nagged at me
all of the different kinds of couples
did fun things together with their
clothes on
but only the man and the woman in the
previous chapter got to take their
clothes off hold this book this book on
sex for my three-year-old it only shows
a man and a a woman having sex it
doesn't show two dudes or two chicks or
three chicks and a goat and it doesn't
you know it does it doesn't certainly
doesn't go far enough for my toddler
this book's well-meaning attempted
inclusivity practically spelled out a
hierarchy of value heterosex is sex
true the other stuff is very loving
though very loving is off-brand so then
that was the that was the bad book that
one wasn't radical enough according to
the new york times so now they're
promoting this other book this other
book is by someone named corey
silverberg
and they include a picture of corey
silverberg
and if you if i told you right now close
your eyes
and picture the kind of grown man who
writes books about sex for little tiny
kids i said just picture
and then you opened your eyes you would
see
the image from your mind
he's a grown man he's got kind of a
weird haircut he's got a kind of creepy
smile
he's got his eyes are looking up his
hand is resting his head is resting
playfully on his hand a little
he's wearing a bright green shirt kind
of groomy shirt he's got some of his
nails painted
and he spends his time
writing
books about sex for little kids why does
he do this
why does he do this he says
it's corey silverberg he's written sex
is a funny word
what makes a baby you know sex
and they've upended the genre silverberg
who uses they pronouns is skeptical of
the term sex positive and would like to
see a world with no
normative pressures
around sex
no
normative pressures
around sex what is a normative pressure
around sex it means rules
it means do this don't do that that
a normative pressure around sex might be
it's better to get married
and
not have sex with lots of people and
just get married and remain in a
monogamous marriage and maybe even be
open to the possibility of that would be
a normative
pressure around sex here's another
normative pressure don't have sex with
little kids
that's a normative pressure around sex
that's saying this is good this is bad
don't do the bad thing do the good thing
that's but we don't
this guy silverberg he's imagining a
world where there are no normative
here's a normative pressure around sex
don't have sex with animals that's
that's a normative pressure no but we we
want a world man
it's going to be so nice when there's no
normative pressures and then we're all
doing things that are completely
degenerate and i think i know exactly
why these people
why
the million-dollar question
why do these people
have to push this stuff on little kids i
think i know the answer the new york
times is pushing really creepy sex books
on little kids little little kids like
preschool little kids
and the new york times is complaining
that these books aren't explicit enough
the books where they show men and women
having sex for three-year-olds but they
don't show two dudes having sex that's
not explicit enough even this really
creepy guy corey silverberg who's
writing these kids sex books and who
says there should be no normative
pressures around sex and who thinks that
he's multiple people and he uses the
they pronoun the new york times is
saying no even he this guy is positively
wholesome compared to the kind of books
that we want we want graphic photos we
are not photos at least illustrations we
want extremely vivid descriptions of
really really creepy perverted sex stuff
for not even just
15 year olds that would be bad enough
not even just eight-year-olds that'd be
really really bad for three-year-olds
for preschool
why
why are these people pushing this stuff
on little kids i think i have an answer
i think
i think the reason and this is i i
imagine a sincere belief of theirs
they think
that everybody just needs to be
degenerate these people are so
degenerate
they are so divorced from any good
standard of living
that they think
that nobody could possibly even aspire
to that good standard of living that
everyone else has to be degenerate too
i'm i'm really not
speaking from the position of being
holier than now or sanctimonious or
saying i never make mistakes i've never
sinned far from it i'm speaking from the
position of
having a standard
that you think is good and that you try
to live up to and that with some work
and prayer and humility and the grace of
god especially the grace of god you
actually can
approach to some degree
you actually can live a more virtuous
life
if you practice the virtues and if you
pray and if you
if you pursue a relationship with god
and you allow god's grace into your life
you that actually can happen
and i think a lot of people today just
don't think that can happen
because we are mired in a culture that
incentivizes and encourages perpetual
vice in a way that wasn't true
even 30 years ago
it's hard for us to imagine because
there's always vice in society there are
always drugs there's always crime
there's always prostitutes there's
always there's always vice everywhere
but there is a difference in degree
even just when we're talking about the
creepy sex stuff that the times is
pushing the very fact that we are now
swimming in a culture of extremely
hardcore pornography and it's just
because people have cell phones and
computers that wasn't true 30 years ago
even just that
is going to change the way that people
view
the possibility of anything even
resembling virtuous living i remember a
friend of mine
some years ago good pal of mine he was
uh going through a little bit of a
wilder phase in his life and he was
getting a little a little wild okay
let's just leave it at that
and we were talking about it one time
and i was like i don't know pal you
really want to keep doing this do you
think you really is this really fun is
this really fulfilling and he said well
you know look it is fun it is very fun
but one thing that i miss
is innocence
he said i miss
i do miss innocence everything now is
kind of jaded and cynical and
people know this
if you get into drugs if you go boozing
too much if you sleep around too much if
you
if you're just slothful if you if you
engage in any of the vices enough
you get really jaded and the world just
doesn't look as beautiful as it once did
you kind of miss
innocence
and the craziest part of that is most
people believe once you lose innocence
you can't get it back you actually can
that is and
people don't really believe it until
until you see it or experience it but
you actually can that's that's what
repentance
does
repentance which is just it just means
changing your mind kind of going in
another direction
when you seek absolution when you seek
forgiveness for your sins when you
try to do better every day at a time
talk to any alcoholic who is in that
bottom pits of despair
and then let's say they've been in aa
for 20 years they've been clean for a
couple of decades now they will be more
innocent they will be more wholesome
they will find joys and pleasure in
things that are more virtuous and good
and innocent and they're they don't just
need to go down to the bar and you know
find their only pleasure at the bottom
of a bottle you actually can regain that
kind of stuff but i think these these
perverts and these degenerates who are
at the new york times and who are
writing sex books for kids and who are
trying to apply kids with cross-sex
hormones and mess up kids and all this
way i think they they genuinely don't
know that
they don't know that there is another
option or they don't believe it even if
they do know that or they don't think
that there's any way for them to improve
their self themselves there actually is
though and it's it's not even just up to
them it's not even just to pull yourself
up by your bootstraps this needs to be
encouraged by the state i can't tell you
you know getting back to the porn thing
i get
letters
constantly from young men who say i i'm
hooked on porn
and it's really hard
yeah that's that's a you that's a you
problem but it's also a political
problem
our country until very very recently we
still have the laws on the books
severely limited porn because they know
that when porn is
widespread and available people are
going to be more likely to to use it and
when people are more likely to use it
it's going to make them a lot worse and
it's going to be really bad for them and
it's going to make their lives a lot
worse and it's going to make the country
a lot worse too and it's going to make
the country less and less able to govern
itself it's not just true of porn this
is why we have laws against certain
drugs it's because with certain drugs if
they're ubiquitous if they're all around
everywhere then it's going to be hard to
resist using them is going to make the
country a lot worse this gets back to an
essay it was written by elle brent
bozell jr
back in 1962 when the postwar
conservative movement was really coming
into shape brent bozell was william f
buckley jr's brother-in-law and friend
from college bill buckley broadly
credited with creating the post-war
conservative movement and it was a
debate on the central issue that was
going on at the time which was the
fusion of the libertarians and the
traditional conservatives
and some people like frank meyer at
national review were encouraging this
fusion and said it made a lot of sense
other people the traditionalists like
brent bozell like russell kirk some
other people were saying i don't think
this is really going to work because
we've got a fundamental
disagreement here the libertarians
believe that the be all and end all of
society is freedom
in their kind of narrow understanding of
it the the maximizing your choice at any
given time
and the traditional conservatives think
that the be all and end all of society
is virtue the good life flourishing
society
so the conservatives love freedom but
they love freedom as an instrument as a
means to an end freedom in its proper
place can help a society prefer
pursue virtue
when we talk about the blessings of
liberty that the founding fathers wrote
about they're viewing liberty in that
way they're saying liberty is good but
what we're really after is the blessings
of liberty
the human flourishing the virtue the
liberty is just a means to an end
that's a fundamental disagreement and
sometimes you'll hear the libertarians
say well we care about virtue too we
care about the good life too but virtue
if it is not totally freely chosen
is not virtuous at all
so you can't have any
any incentives to have live a virtuous
life if if we ban most porn then it's
not virtuous if you don't look at porn
it's only virtuous if
if you have the temptation and you
resist it
okay but if we follow that idea to its
logical end
then the most
virtuous society should be the one that
just floods every everything with porn
right if we follow that idea to its end
then the most virtuous society will be
the one where we've got heroin
everywhere on the street and and it's
being offered to you maybe it's even
being subsidized oh my goodness how
virtuous would you be if you were
offered free heroin and you said no to
it
the most virtuous society would be the
one where every marriage has uh you know
outside of every marital home has a line
of hookers being sent by the state
because if you resist the hookers then
oh my gosh you're the most virtuous guy
in the world right it's absurd it's an
argument that that when taken to its
logical conclusion you can see the
absurdity of it which is what renposel
does in that famous essay freedom or
virtue
i think we we let the
maximizing individual choice people run
the show for a long time on the left and
even
leading the conservative movement
and it's led us to a very bad place
where we're transiting the kids where
we're doing all sorts of terrible things
and where we're now promoting porn for
preschoolers
maybe it's time to try a different
course
everything that the conservatives the
traditional conservatives predicted at
the beginning of this little experiment
in brent bozzell's essay everything they
predicted has come true
everything the right-wingers predict
this country you know you hear about the
slippery slope
well
if we change the definition of marriage
pretty soon we're gonna be changing the
definition of sex and then all the lib
say no that's not true that's great
you're a crazy conservative that's not
what are you talking about well it all
happened it's all been happening
the normalization of pedophilia it's
happening it's all happening
we've got to try a different course
freedom is a great thing we love freedom
but we need to view freedom as the
founding fathers did as the great
americans have
as having a point what's the point of
freedom it's not just so that i can
shoot up heroin gosh wasn't that great i
made the free choice to shoot up heroin
i made the free choice to cheat on my
wife i made the free choice to rob my
neighbor no that's not good
the thing that's the thing that freedom
is for is so you can make the right
choice so you can do the right thing and
by the way even when there are when
there are limitations on your freedom
let's say the state ban certain drugs or
porn or whatever
certain even behaviors
that you still have freedom you still
have moral freedom
moral freedom cannot be take if moral
freedom is real it cannot be taken away
from you
by the state or by anybody else
i'm glad you like that clip folks we're
there we did it well it kind of depends
because we're at a million subscribers
but then i've been talking to people
this morning
and they say michael for whatever reason
i was unsubscribed from your channel so
i think there may be some shenanigans
going on over with our friends at
youtube either way we're teetering on
any given moment 999 999 or 1 million
thank you for bringing us there maybe
ring that bell subscribe make sure that
we are over that threshold then i will
get my trophy then youtube will nuke my
channel and hey it will have been fun
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you